euromaxx highlights and here's your host
cayenne hempstead hi there and a warm
welcome to our highlights of the past
week which are shaping up this time with
these and other stories digital
illusions how's Iman Piero's iPad magic
fools the eye first class fashion who
won the most prestigious style prize in
the world
and action-packed adventure why the new
computer game watch dogs sets new
standards well they do say the hand is
faster than the eye but what about a
computer program take modern tablet
computers for example German illusionist
C Mon Piero uses their already slick
visuals to do some pretty amazing tricks
and proves that modern magic has more
than arrived in the digital age and here
he is in action he can make a spider
crawl out of his screen or make the iPad
fly like a balloon
German magician Zeman Piero has wowed
crowds around the world with his tablet
trickery das mahatmas technics remember
I've always been excited by technology I
had a Filofax when I was 12 I'd enter
all these appointments although I didn't
actually have any I love doing tricks as
well so I decided to combine the two
from the Alana all these doctors will be
binding about something you know those
invisible you can move the ball around a
little food sees how does it feel like a
tablet I'm not make it the right size
and bring it out of the screen Sony's
kinda alpha geek what's up in the house
near you go in here and that can easily
change that
No
it's amazing what doesn't I don't want
to know because that would like take
away it but it's definitely it's cool
the window seats isn't classes it's
different from traditional magic in that
a traditional magician makes things
appear from nowhere like a coin from
behind someone's a year or a tennis ball
out of thin air what is open i combine
that with my tablet I search for eggs
and get the right picture 0 X and then
make it look like the eggs are coming
out of the tablet but I took effect the
season i ax awesome tablet calm but the
digital illusions only work because
Zeman has already mastered some classic
magic skills like sleight of hand he
works with software developer Musashi
bahon to plan his tricks in my new
detail [ __ ] tell it's a locals come to
owner pokum young the art of digital
magic doesn't work without programming
the FIFA that I can't tell you too much
about my secrets of course but obviously
i combine graphic representation on the
iPad with my sleight of hand via special
programming codes for psych here's an
example up here to brush dear to me I
always leave my pen here so I can always
get hold of it so against a kind of yes
I don't feel so good Zeman from the city
of karlsruhe was already a keen
performer as a young boy he got into
magic when he was 16
his career took off in 2002 when he was
named German magic champion since then
he's had TV appearances accolades and
bookings all over the world yep I Maya
nonsan aunty aunty in 1998 I set myself
a goal what it was straight after I
finished school well I was traveling
around America with a friend one day in
the end our car kept breaking down put
the gun at kazaky asked me where I
wanted to be in 10 years when we'd be
laughing about those mishaps I wanted to
be on TV with millions of people
watching my tricks the only switch on my
netflix on
z1 has been posting videos like this one
on YouTube for three years now they've
been viewed by millions of people thanks
to newest technology this is absolutely
fast it is cheap and absolutely payment
he's become known as the iPad wizard on
social media sites thus far for African
jolly as you kind of think a few years
ago I couldn't have imagined this it's
not just being able to do things it's
about who you can show I was lucky to
get onto TV shows but you can't compare
that to the effect YouTube Facebook and
so on have had what's about that
definitely should i get done Zeman is
constantly working on weird and
wonderful new tricks his stunning
performances proved that even in the
digital age people are still fascinated
by the power of magic
well next up we'll look at four very
noble letters LVMH the fashion concerts
among you might know that that's the
acronym for the French luxury goods
conglomerate we're ottumwa Tennessee
which holds the rights to more than 60
luxury brands and not just clothing it
has also undertaken to support promising
young designers and this week just gave
out the very first LVMH young fashion
designer prize in Paris and to the
victors go the spoils namely three
hundred thousand euros in prize money
family Delphine Arnault executive vice
president of LVMH may be at the mic but
she's backed up by some of the world's
top designers there the star-studded
jury for the inaugural young fashion
designer prize was very important to
establish what the criterion was for the
winner and after a long discussion where
each of the designers I think
contributed what they felt it meant to
give this prize we all sort of agreed
that it was about nurturing a young
talent that we'd like to see evolve and
grow and get the help of LVMH so that
they could become you know a powerhouse
designer in in the next ten years in the
running our 12 finalists including
Gabriela Colangelo from Milan
and newcomers Simone palled Jack moose
from Paris among the Dozen hopefuls is
timin lauterbach a german-born KU toliet
who has been living and working in paris
for the last 13 years capturing one of
the most lucrative accolades in the
fashion world would open up new horizons
for the menswear specialists in Fez
Oneida marketing event the person or
brand who wins gets 300 thousand euros
which any designer could do with as it
were to fight if we win I'd open a new
office I have an idea for a small store
very private and very interesting as a
concept the rest would go into
production of course found and rescued
natisha products on dog lauterbach set
up his own label in 2005 the 36 year old
has become an established name on the
scene and his creations feature
regularly at the paris pet apata shows
these two criteria qualified him for the
LVMH prize being under 40 years old and
having at least two ready-to-wear
collections under his belt participation
probably will give this all this design
is so much exposure to
all of us to the world of fashion the
competition drew online applications
from over a thousand budding designers
from across the world a short list of
just 30 were invited to Paris to rub
shoulders with the crème de la crème of
the fashion world Romelu class I'm
trying to imagine being in their shoes
it's an amazing experience but also an
incredible amount of pressure so we're
trying to be especially nice to them no
my place soon that pressure intensifies
as the finalists have their work
scrutinized by the formidable jury
Chanel creative director kalighat fit
his counterpart at louie vito nikoli
ikea and his predecessor Marc Jacobs are
among the big names timin lauterbach
even met his famous compatriot Calaca
fit the social toyota venza men's they
were really friendly they listened and
ask the right questions and we're very
interested too it was great that Olivo
and the winner is Thomas date
the Canadian based in London can look
forward to three hundred thousand euros
in prize money plus a year of mentoring
from the LVMH fashion family I can't
believe it it's a bit like I need to sit
down I almost peed my pants this is site
up really
can believe it like when I heard my name
is the jury were won over by Tate's bold
colors and graphic prints we all felt
that tommasi you know had at the talent
and and was interesting and a new voice
but needs the support and help
financially as well as the tutelage of
available image the winners also a good
fashion illustrator the old master laga
fed got his break fruit from winning a
prestigious fashion competition six
decades ago it gave me my start which is
why I like being in these jurors bekhabi
despite not coming out on top 40
Manitoba the only way is up its eigen
simulants will be in Milan for the first
time we're we're the only designers to
be invited by Italian Vogue to show our
collection so we're preparing for that
great honor I plus we have countless
projects in Tokyo and Asia so I'm
planning to do negative 2 seems like
everyone in this competition is a winner
well this past week the
hotly-anticipated computer game watch
dogs was released it's another of those
really slick productions that's
practically on a par with many a
Hollywood film and while they might not
get a red carpet premiere the
pre-release hype of video games and
those long snaking lineups outside the
stores would be the envy of just about
any movie box office and so we had a
look at the new blockbusters
the star of watch dogs is aiden pearce a
vigilante who uses his smartphone to
manipulate surveillance cameras traffic
lights and even the electricity supply
in a fictional version of chicago how
about you
he can even access the personal records
of his fellow citizens it took the
watchdog's developers five years and 50
million euros to perfect the game
nowadays game designers have to pull out
all the stops to keep players excited
giddap has won every person walking
around in Chicago has their own identity
and when Aiden Pearce interacts with
them something happens in the game he
leaves an impression behind that's part
of the innovation you can't invent
something like that in a year I'm yeah
oh does it all staying video games are
now rivaling Hollywood blockbusters in
cost the game Star Wars The Old Republic
cost 150 million euros it's the third
most expensive computer game ever made
the production and marketing of grand
theft auto 5 costs 200 million euros
just hours after it's released the
game's Scottish manufacturers had recoup
their costs
it hasn't been released yet but destiny
is estimated to have cost a record 360
million euros computer games typically
cost nine figure sums to produce these
days they have to sell a lot of copies
to break even producing a computer game
is not like working on the set of a
feature film where you walk around with
a camera everything you see is created
on a computer so personnel costs are
high that's the biggest cost with danto
one of Germany's biggest training
centers for computer game programmers is
located in trio at the moment the
students are working on one of the
newest gamepad systems the sector is
growing computer games now generate more
income than feature films at the same
time the image of computer games has
changed almost one in two Germans
regularly play computer games nowadays
they're even regarded as cultural assets
which playing business Bob can be it's
not a medium that's regarded as new by
young people as a perhaps was in my
generation back then the defining medium
was television nowadays the computer
game is increasingly becoming the
defining medium for young adults yeah
unboxing today's game designers have to
keep dreaming up bigger and better
tricks for their increasingly demanding
customers to make on-screen movement
look as realistic as possible the
producers use expensive and
time-consuming motion capture technology
actors Don suits kitted out with sensors
and multiple cameras are used the
technology was deployed to particularly
good effect in the game beyond two souls
which hit the market last autumn
hollywood actors ellen page in willem
dafoe were employed by the parisian game
studio quantic dream to create the
characters movements in beyond 2 souls
the distinctions between film and game
become blurred Jesus whether the
charisma of certain actors can be
transferred to virtual characters is
impossible to ascertain at this point in
time that something is meant by my loss
it's been tried once or twice and it was
quite well received they know it's a
long shot we like animation set but
acting on a real set is a little
different from acting on a virtual 10
it's wooden of presenters but games can
be produced without motion capture or
Hollywood actors the independent Swedish
game papers please for example in the
role of a border guard the player
decides whether to allow immigrants to
enter the country despite its relatively
old fashioned graphics the game was
critically acclaimed and recently won
the Lara prize for best international
computer game kidneys Norma don't woman
it's not just about investing more money
being bigger and more realistic or
having better sound effects it's about
creating intelligent entertainment and
depending games can achieve that to
independent games on
the game watch dogs employees impressive
cutting-edge graphics it's a high-gloss
production that could almost be a film
so it should come as no surprise that
there are plans afoot to turn the game
into a movie
well when it comes to cities there's
never getting to the bottom of the
British capital London and what
surrounded is also an itinerary in
itself in fact there's a fabulous tour
that you can take off the castles in and
around London that reveals the
incredible history architecture and of
course the glorious gardens those
castles have to offer and they often
have special exhibitions this year for
instance one commemorating the Georgian
dynasty London drew more overseas
visitors than ever before in 2013 almost
17 million the British capital has
always been a magnet for tourists
shopping the shows and traditional sites
including its array of stately homes the
most famous is Buckingham Palace the
primary residence of the royal family
kensington palace was the final
residents of Princess Diana and is now
home to her son William and his family
kensington palace has an extremely rich
history it was purchased as a tiny
little house in the suburbs of London in
the late 17th century by William the
third and Mary the second and since then
it has been home to members of the royal
family such as George the first George
second princess victoria who became
Queen Victoria he or she was born and
grew up here and subsequently has
remained a royal home in some respects
so the Princess Margaret the Queen
sister lived here during the 1960s and
now at home to the Duke and Duchess of
Cambridge the public area of the palace
had 400,000 visitors last year
it's currently host two glorious
George's an exhibition commemorating the
300th anniversary of the Hanoverian
dynasty George the first became king in
1714 and was followed by three namesakes
his grandson was the last reigning
monarch to use Kensington Palace and his
court was graced by countless cultural
icons of the day we have records of
wonderful parties amazing drawing rooms
that the king and queen held every every
week there were illuminations and the
gardens on a regular basis handle the
composer and his famous Italian opera
singers came here to perform and the
most fashionable people in London came
to spend time here the Georgian eras
legacy extends far outside the hustle
and bustle of central London Q palace in
the Western borough of richmond reflects
the relative modesty of George the third
predating and out pomping Q is Hampton
Court in southwest London first home to
the Tudor kings and queens in the 16th
century it later underwent palladian
m'boro additions before George the first
ordered a lavish refurbishment
Hampton Court is it's a typically
British compromise we like to say
because the Tudor Palace is still there
with a wonderful great battlements and
then there's the Baroque style which is
much more European grandeur very
classical and the two their crash into
each other if you go to the middle of
the palace clock court you'll find Henry
the eighth facing up to the Europeans
are William the third our dutch king and
jaws the first I'll German King side by
side and they plan to pull it all down
and build a brand new palace but of
course being British as they had to be
they didn't have enough money and there
was enough political support so we end
up this wonderful mixture of
architectural styles the Hanoverian
dynasty who today's queen elizabeth is
descended from inherited the throne by a
twist of fate the Act of Settlement in
1701 disqualified Catholics from the
line of succession and so it came that a
German Prince despite his remote
connection to the British royal family
became George the first this anniversary
year offers tourists both special
exhibitions and even a sleepover party
an intimate insight into life at
georgian court the Hanoverian Kings like
their new subjects were keen gardeners
too and every year the palace hosts the
Hampton Court flower show the largest
horticultural extravaganza in the world
by George and need i underscore that
there's never a dull moment here in the
German capital in this past week the D
my design festival opened to showcase
some cutting-edge product and interior
design or more than 500 professionals
from some 30 countries are taking part
in the show which is now over a decade
old and organizers were expecting
upwards of 30,000 visitors well for that
reason it is a great place for young
designers to gain some exposure and so
our reporter checked out this year's
favorites
combining the traditional and the modern
is the concept behind flowers for
slovakia a young design project from
Bratislava the collective of students
and established designers is presenting
its first furniture collection at the DM
Y International Design Festival in
Berlin these objects are so special
because you can really see a poetic
moment interest you can feel that this
is something some symbiosis of these
very old traditional pieces that got
already lost we found them in some barns
and some sellers plus this unique design
pieces from Vietnam so we have this very
modern design part and that is very hand
crafted old traditional things and put
them together five years ago the
designers nas kempe Paola and makalah
lip cova prepared the ground for flowers
for slovakia in the capital bratislava
their objective was to develop
contemporary designs that would
incorporate elements of their home
country's history for their first
project in 2011-12 design students join
them in creating a glass collection
inspired by slovakian fairy tales
what is the connection point between
handle with care and the current
collection is the topic of Slovakia and
the topic of tradition pork on the
current furniture collection began in
July last year the project initiators
took some students along to an old
village in the outback of Slovakia where
they looked around for old pieces of
furniture and acquainted themselves with
traditional cabinetmaking methods
I feel folk art installer here is in a
way shared with the region we are in
with Central Europe we were using very
simple things made from the resources we
had like food and linen and in a way
this simplicity is very charming and I
think this is something better did not
there is not very much seen in Slovak
design and we would like to wake it up
the 15 design students modify the
historical pieces for several weeks
adding elements by the renowned Swiss
furniture maker Vita the final result
was the 17 handmade one-of-a-kind pieces
of the Lost and Found collection
I think this objects are very unique and
very authentic and this is maybe topic
also for our international design sorry
of already vanity you have to be
authentic and very very unica to be
interesting for audience back in Berlin
more than 150 exhibitors from the world
over are presenting their latest
creations in a hangar at the
decommissioned Tempelhof Airport the
Slovakian designers are among the
frontrunners for the award the DM Y is
one of Germany's biggest arenas for
young product designers and an
opportunity for up-and-coming designers
to network we don't know what our next
season will look like which kind of
materials we will use but this is this
one thing is really for sure we really
want to create a new unique objects
again and we want to find really highly
motivated people it's a formula that's
proving successful after Berlin the
collection will be moving on to London
and Milan
and that's all for this edition of our
euromaxx highlights hope you enjoyed it
and until we meet again alliston trip on
spelling on obviously
you